i i think that
um
the level of quality for vr and the fact
that it's tetherless or neat a little
that everlast is the job that we needed
for vr
and i
again personally think that we we can
have something that's as easy to wear as
um just regular sunglasses
um
that would open up
like the the
wide use cases around the world and
there are crazy use cases
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitech and
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel stanford leap
and birthright excel
hello and welcome to another episode of
20 minute leaders today i'm going to
talk to gilar talmon the ceo of tetavi
gila talmon is 46 and is married to gali
and the father to zoe and healy he has
been a gamer since the early 80s and
that is why he shifted from a 20-year
long career in defense aerospace and
cyber to immersive media
gilad has senior management experience
in both a startup and corporate setting
spanning a variety of technological
disciplines gilad is the ceo of tetuvi a
pioneering immersive social
entertainment for consumers and
professionals by introducing volumetric
video to the masses and shaping the
future of the metaverse
[Music]
welcome to 20 minute leaders how are you
i'm fine i'm fine how are you thanks for
having me
thank you so much for being here i'm so
excited to talk about gaming sci-fi
metaverse entertainment uh so much cool
stuff that is happening that i know so
little about so this is gonna be one of
those episodes that i'm just gonna look
back on and i'm so excited for it and
thank you very very much for joining me
today you're running tethy you you have
such an interesting background you know
not not coming from the traditional
route into the gaming world and so i'd
love to hear a little bit about your
journey but and then hear about you know
how you perceive you know metaverse and
gaining in today's world and where we're
headed so glad tell me a little bit
about yourself a little bit about your
upbringing and how you've entered into
this world of gaming
so actually for the transitioning to
gaming for me was pretty much natural um
because i've always been a gamer uh
most of the rest of the things that i
did during my career were fun
far less natural for me at least um
i i joined tetavi about three and a half
years ago i'm not one of the founders
i'm the ceo one of the founders is one
of my best friends and um
it's funny it started
because i'm a geek
we we have this
game night that we do every thursday
board games and we've been doing it for
ages um
and i was working for a cyber security
company as kind of the cro
um and michael the co-founder of cto um
we were talking about what he's doing
with the company and he told me about
what they're doing and he said you know
you should come over and see what we're
doing because you like it he knows that
i'm a gamer he's a gamer as well
um and we were actually looking for a
ceo for um ceo and i immediately told
him not interested and he said what do
you care come
um
and then i
come to the company it was still in the
kodak building uh like there were two
algorithm designers one programmer and
michael pretty much
uh who kind of ran r d
and he shows me this demo of him dancing
he's an awful dancer really really awful
but him dancing in in 3d on the computer
and i go like how did you do that
and then he
walks me through it and i told him well
i'm in
no brainer um this is
tell me a little bit about that moment
that made you
stop and say i'm in because i'm always
curious about those moments you're
working on something you know that's
that's the world that you're in and all
of a sudden you're exposed to something
else and you're saying you know what i i
want to be doing this
well
again it goes back to my background um
think about it i'm i'm 46
um my father was one of the first
computers and engineers in israel uh way
way way back in the late 60s um early
70s he designed the computer architect
the software architecture for the evos
um so i've had computers around me all
the time and when i started gaming it
was still then you know the text you
enter a room blah blah and then you
needed to guess what the right keywords
are in order to progress and then move
through um
entering into 2d games and then the
first 3d games etc etc and and i came up
till now i i
need to send hate mail to somebody who
just introduced me to the new amazon
game uh the new world because i spent
the last two days uh awake until three
a.m playing in
um
because that's the free time that i have
no part of the business recent walk okay
or
at least that's what i told my wife um
um well seriously uh
think about when i grew up then we had
star trek and star wars and and a lot of
these it's around the whole deck and
around the interface you know the
princess leah hologram how they
communicate and how you can create this
sense of intimacy and communication and
and also gaming gaming really progresses
towards the
the place where it's starting to be this
social space that can connect
everyone i remember when we were used to
we used to do world of warcraft and we
had our own guild in world of warcraft
the cutoff uh age was around 30. uh in
the beginning we didn't even even have
voice over ipv voice over ib
came in
um you know during the time that we were
playing like pretty much in the middle
of where the guild was at its uh height
we had a few hundred players from all
around the world
it got to the point where we socialized
so much and think about it again in the
beginning novose over ip it was all
shorthand um
texting right and emote right
we actually had a gathering of some of
the guild members in ireland meeting and
we set up this
local computer network so we could all
link in together and play actually
wow in the real world and it it became
this kind of social circle i still have
you know i still maintain relations
mainly over facebook with some of the
people who are playing with it and
then when i see my daughters now
uh i have a 10 year old and a 15 year
old and the amount of time that they
spent not so much gaming mainly in
roblox and and minecraft but just
socializing with friends all over the
world it's nuts
um
that's what i saw that was the aha
moment i i had like a flashback into
specifically the holodeck that's
not because of me i i don't take credit
our vp rnd is also a huge turkey so a
lot of our demos we put
a kind of holodeckish
style environment where we show our
captures in
um
because really for me
i don't even remember if it was before
after i joined tetavia did you have a
chance to see the the netflix show that
they did with the move with the the
books around the art of the carbon
yes yes i did
so he walks there in the street and then
you see that he's starting to get these
really in your face commercials well
they're all
in the the half of the world is ar or
projected holograms and he can then
start decluttering and removing
you know maintaining some information
removing other information communicate
through a
i really really believe that if you look
at the way that kind of science fiction
uh um put it together even 20 30 years
ago and the way that tech is progressing
we're heading in that direction
uh kind of what is stopping us so so as
you're you know i think that one one of
the questions that i always have because
obviously you know there's a lot of
excitement around and we're seeing a lot
of people working on this and we're
seeing sci-fi movies talking about this
for quite some time
what why are we not advancing as quickly
as as as we'd like is it the technology
is it the consumer side is it the
regulations
regulations will probably kick in when
we actually start getting it
and as always regulation will follow and
not lead
and i think that it's fine don't take me
the wrong way i think that regulations
should follow and lot lead
well unless you know
russia um but um
there are two issues some of them are
getting solved the first issue is
communication this takes you need to
overhaul like huge chunks of data and in
in in a sense both 5g edge computing and
what's happening in the cloud this will
pretty much solve that the second thing
is the viewing devices the the viewing
devices although we'll we're seeing a
big progress in viewing devices we're so
far off from the holodeck
uh experience so even ultra carbon uh
just wearing uh eye contacts um which
make all of this seamless that it's
still clunky where do you see it really
shine in in the gaming world the gaming
world people are used to the 3d language
over 2d screens people are used to
sitting in front of the computer and
immersing themselves and that's why i
think again my personal opinion opinion
um
uh games like fortnite roblox uh
minecraft are so successful and um the
the immersive performances that that you
saw whether italiano grande or travis
scott orlinas was so successful it's
it's a language that people like us who
grew
in a gamified world and were gamers or
especially kids like my daughter that
you know
they never knew another world
like playing in the yard with
peach seeds
the language is much more natural to
them when we get the viewing devices
that are more comfortable i think that
that's like the missing piece and we're
getting them the companies like
motovision while developing the eye
lenses uh i think that the quest
too especially it was a huge leak
um
before quest to
uh even
for me personally as a very again i'm an
early adopter geek live technology in
any shape way or form our house is
again i hope my wife doesn't hear this
ever
full of useless gadgets and toys
there's an i told you so somewhere in my
future though um
and uh uh i couldn't like i tried a lot
of the vr stuff and i could never go
back then the first set that i could
really go back to is the quest two and
we'll see more and more and more of
these sets coming out i had a chance to
uh try and enjoy the um
valve uh the uh i forgot the name but
the the new one that they have with the
144 hertz that's amazing and i can't
wait to see what the next generation for
microsoft is and um what the next
generation of the ar and what the next
generation of the facebook and the
oculus is and what the next generation
of the apple is although they're not
officially announcing it they're leaking
it crazy um
because
i think that
um
the level of quality for vr and the fact
that it's tetherless or neat and
everlast is the job that we needed for
vr
and i
again personally think that we we can
have something that's as easy to wear as
um just regular sunglasses
um
that would open up
like the the uh wide use cases around
the world and there are crazy use cases
everything from yeah
to advertisement to uh uh just think
somebody told me it's not it's not my
idea so i'm quoting somebody but i admit
and i apologize to whomever that was
that i don't remember so i can't give
credit but again it's not mine
um
the combination of ar 5g and glasses
that you can actually wear or something
that is wearable can make all of us
superhuman
think about you and we just had this
case here in our street somebody got
cardiac arrest in the middle of the
street and he sadly passed away uh but
they were resuscitating him for about an
hour
um
think about being able to access
immediately in ar everything that you
need to do in this type of
curse just you get it full volumetric
see exactly how to do resuscitation how
do you it's the use cases can really
really augment human capabilities and
that's the real potential gaming is fun
and again i love gaming but the
potential of metaphors in the sense of a
layered reality from ar to via through
gamified environments is huge
i i love that perspective i love the
perspective that you bring that it's not
just you know you were looking we're
entering this conversation from a gaming
and entertainment perspective but but
the the fact that you know we're
actually entering a new era of the way
that we communicate with the world and
the way that we experience the world and
it actually has some
you know on you know benefits that we
that are that are not the ones that are
making the headlines right and these are
but these are obviously things that we
should be cognizant of
yeah
how um waze changed our life in
navigating i i still remember the time
when you traveled abroad and you either
had uh you you needed to buy gps
pre-loaded and even before that
no way you're driving
think about what will happen when you
don't really need ways because
everything is superimposed you need to
go somewhere and like in a game like in
um you know gta or something you'll just
have it marked on your reality
and you get the clutter in and out so
you don't have to have it there
um and it can give you recommendations
because it knows what you want and it
can um just think of
it's um an idea that my daughter had
we're talking about some applications
where we will enable people just any
consumer to generate um automatic video
okay anyone it won't require the
professional system anyone can do it not
exactly how exactly does it matter but
anyone could do it so my daughter said
now we've covered imagine we could have
done a greeting where uh
you know my wife and i and daughters and
my brother and his wife and his kids um
just build an ar greeting for my parents
you know their birthday or their you
know um
marriage uh
anniversary and they could have all of
us give it to them in their living room
you can do that there's so much around
it with again i mean it's not just for
greetings i mean today the loneliness
epidemic is one of the is one of the you
know worst epidemics that there are we
know we talk a lot about covet but when
we're talking about socializing and and
the need even pre-covet it's it's
incredible and and the solutions like
this can completely change the way that
we interact with each other and allow us
to interact with family members that are
overseas for people that don't have the
ability to get out and come to events
like weddings and bar mitzvahs i mean
the possibilities are endless
yeah so just two examples in that
respect and um i think that again now i
know whom i'm quoting so mark talked
about that you know this gives you a
sense of presence because something
that's lacking in in this type of
communication or both of us in 2d um
is um it's it's a much more
uh personalized way of communication
because i can see how you react to what
i say and it's you still get some body
language but it's not
not as if you're here something that uh
vr and ar have the potential of creating
is really a sense of presence of me
being in the room we did this project
with the um uh office of the president
ruby rivlin when he gave greetings uh
well it was already a couple of years
ago for
israel independence day and they got
really really good reactions because he
finished it was in ar and you can bring
him into your living room and he gave
this like i can't bring you into my
living room because of coffee so i'm
coming to you blah blah and then um
at the end he said well let's kind of
you know do a picture together and they
got thousands and thousands and
thousands of pictures with
just kids and family members and entire
family you know uploaded to their
website
and um
because it brings a sense of presence
and the second thing that it can it
really has the potential of doing and
it's something that started already and
again i always like to give my daughters
as examples because you know they live
the space and they're just
when it's something used younger and
with access to all of these gadgets you
know when i couldn't when i actually had
the time to use them um
and not at 3am uh she has she's part of
a fan club for stranger things
and before coffee we went to stranger
con in london
um
and she has
like she's part of the international
club she has friends all over the world
they're they're so socialized and
they're meeting roblox all the time and
they meet and speak and the talk and the
friends that last christmas hanukkah
they had a secret santa global through
amazon
wow that is for somebody like me when we
wanted to communicate with the world and
again it's not that i'm ancient i'm 46
like i'm ancient ish
i wasn't holding dinosaurs but you know
i saw some of them before they died but
uh we needed to have we had this thing
with uh radios
am radios with one of our classmates had
this radio and if you wanted to
communicate with people around the world
you'd go and then had this huge antenna
and you started getting your call sign
around hoping somebody would pick it up
wow they meet a regular basis kids from
the us japan europe israel middle east
around the middle east with a common
interest and they play
with amazon it's nuts
how do you perceive this relationship
that they're forming in comparison to
the relationships that you knew growing
up and you know today
i think it has disadvantages and
advantages and i'll tell you why
specifically both of my daughters are
very
like friendly so they have their own
social circle here in israel as well so
they meet with friends and they go out
etc it's not just they don't sit in the
same room texting each other
um
and then i think that it's mainly
positive there are the dangers of the
internet etc and you know
the big one is already responsible and
it's very socialized into it for the
young one we do some more monitoring but
i think that it gives them exposure to
different cultures and different people
in the way that we just didn't have
uh we
again my generation uh if you didn't
relocate abroad with your family uh got
exposure to other cultures through tv
but you didn't really meet the people
behind it
zoe knows knows personally people from
all around the world she knows the
dilemmas of kids her age again in
the middle east europe africa
the us you communicate with them on a
regular basis and i think that it's very
in the long run again talking about the
benefits of kind of metaphors and where
the sense of presence can bring us and
how
how much of a unifying um inclusive
experience it can be i think the
potential is huge
talking about regulation again not
government regulation i think that it is
important though to make sure that it
doesn't become toxic
um and i was very very pleasantly
surprised and still am uh on how
inclusive it is
or how inclusive the zoe's experiences
and how
um
and how much of an educational
experience it is for her because again
it's that there's a tipping point where
when you're far away uh especially you
know all of these whatsapp groups etc
they can become really toxic
i think that part of it again is the
sense of presence the fact that you're
with the kids there and it's a community
there's repetitiveness uh you're there
in the virtual environment it's still
your avatar hopefully again in the
future it won't be your other right will
it be you but it's still your avatar and
it's still a community and it has its
rules and so it works kind of like the
uh schoolyard just in a virtual sense
um again for me the experience that we
had is amazing i think it's a literal
glimpse into the future and the fact
that
we're actually trying to enable some of
that future for me it's very satisfying
i um somebody recruiting somebody now uh
for senior position we're going after
the next round so we're recruiting the
stuff in
the executive business staff in the us
so uh one of the um
guys when i spoke with him he's going to
come from corporate he asked me if i'm
having fun and it got me thinking yes i
am having fun loads of fun
fun in levels that i never had when i
was working corporate but because i i
like the people that i worked with some
of them are some of my best friends
until now but it's it's so different
it's being immersed in something that
i've been dreaming about since i was a
young kid and wow for me it's like
being
you know a kid in a candy store
i love it i just love it and and gilad
thank you so much for for taking the
time to share this with me there's so
much more that that i wish to talk to
you about and so i'm already booking you
for another episode that is going to be
specifically about tetavi because we
didn't talk really about 3d presence and
the incredible things that you're doing
there but i just loved loved hearing
your perspective and really you know
your excitement into this whole new
world that we're venturing into you know
we're so occupied with the world that
we're in and we're forgetting that you
know our children our grandchildren are
going to be experiencing a whole
different world and i think it's time to
think a little bit more critically about
what the world is going to look like and
and the values that are going to be
there and and adopt it and not and not
fight it so glad thank you very very
much i appreciate your time and stay
safe and stay healthy
thank you very much you as well
you